watches and the age that we live in
there are pretty amazing watches out
there right there's a lot of different
types but in this video we're only gonna
focus on the best fitness watches so
let's not waste any more time let's get
right into the video
[Music]
make mistakes but mistakes make you
strong hey guys welcome to my channel
I'm Daniel and if this is your first
time here subscribe click the
notification bell and then you won't
miss any of the next videos now let's
start with the first fitness tracker
watch first up and probably the most
expensive is the Apple watch a series 4
it'll cost you around $400 expensive yes
but if you have the money it is worth it
these two times faster than the old
3-series because of its new 64-bit
dual-core processor this watch can do so
many stuff but I don't have the time to
talk about it in full detail but as
always I'll add it free in the video
description down below just like all the
other watches so you can go and check it
out and do your own research as well
what I gotta mention a few stuff about
this watch it's got a whole new design
he's got a proactive health monitor
automatic workout detection a
comprehensive activity tracker and much
much more
but let's move on to the next watch now
if you're on a budget and you want a
cheaper watch then the willful fitness
tracker is the watch that you want to
get it comes listen to this at only $33
yeah it's a bit cheap so I said I was a
bit shocked and I wandered ahead is this
really good for only $33 so I did a bit
of research and it is actually really
good it's also one of Amazon's top
choices and if you go and you click the
link that I've had a free interview
description check out the customer
reviews and you'll see that there's over
300 of people that's very happy with it
so what do you get for the $33 well you
get a fitness tracker the heart rate
monitor sleep monitor it also comes in
different colors that you can choose
from the Fitbit Versa SmartWatch is
almost 2 times cheaper than the Apple
series 4 and it goes around for $200
this is my most favorite watch because
it's a good quality watch that has over
15 exercise modes it's got 4 day battery
life in stores music and you can put
your favorite fitness apps on it it also
has a 24/7 heart rate tracking where you
can track your calorie burn and discover
your cardio fitness level there's a lot
of other cool stuff that this watch can
do but I don't want this video to be too
long that's it for now check it out in
the video description if you liked the
video keep it a thumbs up subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video
Cheers
[Music]
you